oh my God oh my God don't chew my shoe
don't do my shoe beautiful lady I really
like you oh no three puppies are on the
loop
I'm Emily Ratajkowski and I'm here with
BuzzFeed to play with puppies this is
crazy but you guys came up with it like
whoever came up with this is a sicko
like it's genius
I hear them puppies are coming copy that
oh my goodness hello
hi Papa oh my
oh my oh my God oh my God hi babies
wow oh my God another one
[Music]
um puppies honestly right now I'd love
to have Pamela Anderson I'm working on
that I really would love to see Aubry
Plaza Doja cat it was kind of a lot
this is so hard
um I didn't at first because I was just
like every person has a podcast and I
don't want to be another person with a
podcast after I like wrote my book and
stuff it just made sense for it to be
kind of the next thing in an extension
of that
oh my God I definitely win Donatella
Versace came to New York for the podcast
and she was like I'm gonna come but I
need to dress the set with Versace
pillows and like brought me like an
embezzled um or um embezzled just like a
beautiful bedazzled like cup for me to
drink of out of that said Versace on it
and I was just like how is this real
life basically wow this one is beautiful
I did get to keep the cat and my son Sly
loves to drink from it now so it's
hilarious because it's basically the
size of him
but honestly I think with interviews you
kind of want to get like the juicy scoop
a little bit and that's so not my
instinct to do that to my guests because
I hate when people have done that to me
people feel comfortable with me and want
to have like you know genuine
conversations where they're opening up
it's been good yeah I really like you
thank you
I hear myself going
um going like no or going sorry I'm so
distracted by these puppies I'll say
like yeah a million times and or like
totally I get it and it's like you don't
need to respond
ah
it's been so crazy I like to spend as
much time with him as possible but then
also I'm traveling all the time for
other jobs like I was just in Poland
last week which is amazing but it's just
um it's a lot I don't know I don't have
like some secret people are like oh how
do you do it and I'm like I don't know
day by day basically
I love this
what's up Mike White
this is my audition tape I heard the
next one's going to be in India so I
don't know I'm I'm available for any
casting I will say I related the most to
Aubrey Plaza in the last
last season I wanted to be the Italian
girls but unfortunately I'm more about
reposit character
my best friends
um Babs and cats
um definitely I would do an iCarly
regret I only did like two episodes but
the streets love it I get called Tasha
on the internet a lot which I'm honored
I'm not gonna lie I didn't do like a
full character build out of Sasha for
iCarly I don't know I feel like she's
she's married maybe she's a kid maybe
she's like me maybe she's doing exactly
what I'm doing oh the bodies so don't
chew my shoes don't do my shoe beautiful
ladies
I want to see Ugg boots come back I was
thinking about this like I really want
like comfy trashy clothes to come back
obviously
um and then what would I not want to
come back low-rise jeans like I have a
I don't know how I feel about it I own
some I know they're back but I don't
know that I need them to be back hi
I take naming very seriously when I
named my dog Colombo he's named after
this like
um Italian Steak and like jazz bar in
Eagle Rock in La that I love called
Columbo's it came to me it was like an
epiphany Sly my son is named after not
named after but kind of from Sly and the
Family Stone I'd need time I can't I
can't do it they just oh no they're
breaking out hi so
Kim and I have dmmed she's probably like
the most famous person in the world but
I think that counts oh no three puppies
are on the loose
oh my God my dog is gonna freak out when
I get home
right now I'm getting a lot of like what
stage of capitalism is this and it'll be
like uh black lives matter protest like
an ad in the background I've been
getting those the last couple days right
now I'm getting a lot of Shakira
obviously I've been on like crazy
different parts of tick tock where I'm
like why I shouldn't be here honored to
be on lesbian Tick Tock for a minute but
I was like I'm not a lot like I
shouldn't be here but I enjoyed it
I'd honestly just like go out dancing
for like a whole week because there's
kind of nothing worse than being out and
around a lot of drunk people when you're
famous because it just like everyone's
like yo you know and that would be fun
to just do a week where like nobody
cared or nobody know this
thank you
I don't know my fans are pretty great I
have like a lot of like young women come
up to me I've gotten um some really
amazing letters that fans have given me
talking about reading my book and stuff
that just like really touched me and
about very special
I remember the first time I went to the
Oscars like after parties I grew up my
parents love the Beatles And I was like
on the dance floor and Paul McCartney
was dancing next to me and I was like my
parents are going to die I was just like
what how is this real life oh Beyonce I
got so I said some stupid I was
like because I'm no swans and she was
like oh have you met my sister
your sister I was also a little drunk I
was at the Met no you can't take the
wire no I will never approach I'm way
too scared
this is so dorky but I would like reread
all the Harry Potters thinking about how
Sly has not is going to get to read all
the Harry Potters and I was just like
that's so wow because that was like my
whole childhood
I don't think anyone would be surprised
but I auditioned for the role in
Triangle of sadness which tracks a lot
of people have been like hey wait you
like whatever like this makes sense for
you and I'm like yep no please don't eat
my boobs
[Music]
they keep escaping how are you escaping
how are you escaping how are you
escaping their bellies and your skin is
so soft I think it was met 2019 I wore
this like kind of like homage to share
and I just I was so nervous and didn't
know if it was going to look good and
then I like looked back I'm like all
right that look good I like those
pictures so hi
the last TV show I binge watched was
White Lotus it was annoying to me that I
had to wait every week for a new episode
come here uh thank you so much for
watching thank you BuzzFeed This was oh
oh those little tiny puppy teeth and go
check out my new podcast Hi-Lo with
emrata wherever you listen to your
podcast all of these puppies are
adoptable at North Shore Animal League
America everyone should have their
rescue on
look at these babies it's amazing that
I'm not gonna go home with one of them
so one of you should